j'ai envie de te poser des questions les
yeux dans les yeux one vas-y tu vas me
poser je te poser les questions que je
me dis la vérité oui parce que les
téléspectateurs à 19h18 ils attendent la
vérité autant à 22h05 c'est un sujet
grave donc la laison chedjou attend la
vérité
sandrine oui lequel est la vraie raison
de ton départ de tf1
parce que j'avais envie de jouer de la
comédie je vais là comme on dit j'arrive
à ma question privée tf1
non je ne pouvais pas en faire chez tf1
puisque j'étais animatrice chez tf1 et
que non seulement je pouvais pas en
faire mais en plus je n'avais pas le
temps d'en faire ta pensée peut-être à
faire joséphine ange gardien
oui on n'a pas messi a pas de sot un
petit paradis tout ça parce que le mari
madame si c'était un truc préféré de ma
mère est ici je suis pas fâché du tout
avec tf1 et j'ai déjà tourné pour tf1 et
je vais retourner pour tf1 d'accord très
bien très bien très bien très bien très
bien donc c'est votre décision
ce départ de tête c'est ma décision
sirène comment ça s'est passé vous êtes
arrivé vous avez été par le patron et 20
juillet j'arrête tout oui je vais pas
dit comme ça mais je lui ai dit c'était
je sais plus au mois d'octobre ou
novembre je lui ai dit que voilà j'ai
envisagé d'arrêter au mois de décembre
parce que j'avais eu des propositions de
fiction a crevé et que je voulais voilà
je voulais terminer au mois de décembre
danse avec les stars sa copine
s'installer c'est un peu le temps de se
retourner pour tout le monde et j'avais
vraiment besoin de tout arrêter et de
plus rien à voir pour me mettre au pied
du mur et pour pouvoir
et bien voilà me donner toutes les
chances alors il a du courage ce que
vous aviez une place en or soit il avait
complètement bousillé danse avec les
stars mine de rien toutes les semaines
nous étions prime time avait plein de
printzheim 50 minutes inside
non mais c'est pour ça que je fais je
cracherai jamais dans la soupe j'ai eu
des naufrages pas mal d'années sur tf1
mais mais mais quand j'avais envie
d'évoluer j'avais envie d'autre chose et
plus de télé mais vraiment oui mais la
preuve gardien que ça fait deux ans que
j'ai arrêté tu m'as est elle beaucoup de
propositions j'ai quelques propositions
wiki sur m6 j'ai eu des propositions oui
france télévisions c'est inouï j'ai eu
quelques soldats sur le sol et france
télévisions ou
bah c'est pas parti pour faire ce que tu
m'as marché d'enfer france 2 france 2
quelques propositions voilà alors de
balai sur france 2 non mais t'as pas et
n'a pas voulu nommer sans franchement je
le dis aux téléspectateurs il faut un
courage immense ça parce que je peux te
poser une question oui ils s'opposent
aussi oui financièrement et divisé par
quatre voilà ça c'est un truc donc tout
à diviser par 4 oui parce que tu gagnes
est extrêmement bien et très bien ma vie
ouais j'avais des deux côtés j'avais mis
un prêt d'argent côté g20 pour vif et
rêve oui ex vivo leur ai dit je vivais
mes rêves donc voilà j'espère je l'avais
anticipé que gagnerait beaucoup moins
cher
[Applaudissements]